quelques mois j'étais à barcelone et je
vous parlais du nouveau smartphone de
sony et notamment du sony xperia one ce
joli smartphones enfin plutôt ce joli
smartphone qu'il est vraiment hyper
intéressant il fait plein de promesses
et il les tient alors il ya aussi
quelques points négatifs on attend la
question à se poser c'est est-ce que ce
sony xperia one peu séduit peut séduire
oui non quoi comment on regarde ça
maintenant
[Musique]
avant de parler du sonics byron je vais
vous parler d'un jeu pas si vous êtes un
gamer soit si vous jouez si vous je veux
sans smartphone vous parler d'un jeu qui
s'appelle wade shadow les jeun's c'est
une vidéo qui est sponsorisé par shadow
les viols merci beaucoup pour
s'autoriser cette vidéo si vous le savez
pas wade shadow les jeunes massés en rpg
rpg qui cartonne qui a des causes qui
sont vraiment intéressants qui moussent
qu un petit peu la donne et qui est
assez cool en quelque chose comme 3 mois
vous êtes plus de 10 millions
d'utilisateurs qui ont utilisé le jeu
dans le monde entier donc un gros succès
derrière tout ça le scénario est super
cool les graphismes à la hauteur le
gameplay passionnant avec beaucoup de
stratégie derrière il ya des batailles à
des boss géants et vous avez plus de 400
champions à obtenir alors les champions
sont vos personnages vous avance dans la
voiture que vous avez le champion ou
plus peuvent avoir des marqueurs à nous
coller fait de ce thème du rpg tout cas
c'est vraiment intéressant moi vos
chansons préférées
c'est lui c'est galec alors pour
l'instant je suis qu'au niveau 2 mais
franchement il envoie du bois que ce
soit l'armée
c'est pas mal de choses c'est vrai qu'il
est assez impressionnant alors que notre
champion j'ai aussi sniper qui est un
marché qui va m'envoyer plein de flèches
qui va les buts et les ennemis et qui
est super cool et j'en ai un troisième
c'est lui c'est le barbare pareil
archers impressionnant et franchement
hyper cool c'est un jeu qui est sympa
qu'un grand univers ya plein de champion
disponibles garder un peu pour tous les
goûts tous préféré aller guerroyer vous
pouvez y aller il ya un gameplay qui est
vraiment sympa c'est préférer avoir des
champions vous pouvez en collectionner
enfin vraiment ce que vous voulez c'est
un jeu qui est complètement gratuit il
ya des batailles pvp en marraine des
batailles pve dans des donjons et des
batailles avec des boss géants j'ai
découvert un jour dessus depuis quelques
temps j'aime beaucoup d'ailleurs
s'ajouter quand même pas mal de notes on
est quasiment 25 étoiles sur le ps store
ce jeu sympa il ya plein de mise à jour
sur les stores ya plein de monde de fûts
et en plus il a un programme qui est
sympa pour les nouveaux joueurs vous
obtenez des récompenses quotidienne
pendant 90 jours
je vous invite à venir essayer et
télécharger le jeu directement par les
liens dans la description pour obtenir
50 milles en argent rien que de l'argent
pour vous et un champion épique gratuit
dans le cadre du programme nouveaux
joueurs pour commencer ce jeu si vous
voulez venir rejoindre même chercher
directement sous le nom de monsieur
heureux vous invitez revient laissagais
sur rail os ou android vous avez les
liens en bas dans la description et
maintenant il est là
de parler du xperia one-x paris sorbonne
qui est bien justement pour venir jouer
dessus mais pour beaucoup d'autres
choses c'est un smartphone qui a
beaucoup de qualités et à commencer par
son écran les smartphones et les écrans
des terrains deviennent commencent à
arriver de plus en plus ils experia
thèmes que je restais ya pas longtemps
disparue at elle plus explicite steria
10 plus de le faire reprendre et ça ira
beaucoup mieux et notamment son
expérience que j'avais vraiment hâte de
tester parce que j'aime beaucoup ce
format c'est un format qui est assez
long mais qui à ses fins qui se tient
bien en main ça c'est bien m en point
négatif c'est comme il est très haut et
bien vous allez utiliser comme ça il
faut utiliser à deux mains pour venir
gratter en eau
sinon c'est tout juste un petit peu
compliqué à à côté de ça lorsque vous
venez serrer comme ça vous avez les
raccourcis vous pouvez avoir directement
ici sont plutôt pas mal mais c'est vrai
que malgré tout c'est un smartphone
convenir vraiment utilisé à demain la
prise en main est bien mais il est grand
en effet 170 g
il est résistant solide avec corning
gorilla glass 6 donc ça c'est vrai qu'on
est plutôt rassuré là dessus vous avez
ici sur le côté votre bouton de volume
le capteur d'empreintes digitales de
boutons pour l'allumer pointe toujours
surprenant de se dire que le capteur
d'empreintes digitales n'est pas un
bouton en fait pour l'allumer pour
l'éteindre tron qui marche très bien
vous avez le bouton qui est juste en
dessous sur lequel vient de toi
peut-être réunir ces deux boutons en un
seul bon c'est pas non plus hyper hyper
grave
vous avez ici chaque côté un petit
bouton qui va dire déclenché vos photos
le freestyle votre appareil hop vous
appuyez ça déclenche ça fait une photo
ça c'est assez marrant offrant une somme
de sous un haut parleur de l'usb tilt
c'est votre micro ici sur le côté
absolument rien et vous retrouver ici
votre tiroir avec votre carte sim et 26
tensions mémoire oublier le petit micro
pour la réduction de bruit à l'arrière
vous avez un trip module photo qui vous
expliquer en quelques instants le
branding sony xperia bien ce qui est
vachement bien que ce smartphone c'est
le parti pris il a longtemps été
reproché à celui d'avoir des smartphones
pas hyper beau pas hyper sexy et de
reste toujours sur un design un petit
peu trop old school se remette en
question une avance il progresse et je
trouve qu'avec ce xperia voyant quelque
chose qui est vraiment très bien abouti
le smartphone est vraiment beau il ya
vraiment des finitions très premium
hyper cali est là pour l'instant je vous
parle uniquement du design
un des points majeurs de ce smartphone
c'est son écran vous avez un écran de
6,5 pouces de diagonale oled 4k hdr 3842
résolution par 1664 c'est juste un écran
énorme avec un ratio 21/9 c'est l'écran
cinéma wild s'est vraiment l'écran fait
pour regarder des séries pour avoir du
contenu multimédia c'est le format
cinémascope
c'est vraiment beau ce un écran qui est
hyper bien calibrer la colorimétrie et
toc la couleur et hop la luminosité
bien c'est pas le smartphone le plus
lumineux mais dans l'absolu c'est quand
même plutôt bien la faim en plus d'un
moteur de traitement d'image x1 pour
mobiles
il est vraiment bien vous avez en plus
un mode créateur my sin et alta qui est
top
l'idée de ce smartphone c'est vraiment
de vous restituer la meilleure
expérience la meilleure image la
meilleure qualité notamment vis-à-vis
d'un rendu professionnel et vous le
voyez dans les paramètres vous allez
dans un fichage vous allez choisir la
qualité l'image alors vous êtes par
défaut sur le mode standard qui est un
peu plus bleuté au niveau de l'écran
passés sur le mode créateur il offre une
reproduction fidèle de la vision
souhaité par le créateur au moyen de
l'écran 4k et d'un traitement d'image
spécialement développé compatible avec
la gamme de couleurs bt 2020 et la
profondeur des couleurs 10 bits de la
recommandation hdr un truc qui est
vachement bien fait alors soit vous
l'activez en permanence sauf que c'est
mieux parce que ça me donnait un côté un
peu plus jaune et un petit peu moins
bleu par rapport aux mots standard
néanmoins que les vols standard pouvait
dire relative est automatiquement
lorsque vous êtes sur du contenu qui est
optimisé perso je laisse le mode
créateur en permanence et ça c'est
parfaitement bien et pour regarder des
séries au format 21 9ème c'est vraiment
tout simplement génial parce qu'il ya un
côté très immersif très cinéma et je
trouve ça vraiment beau que ce soit sur
netflix ou que ce soit également sur
youtube vous venez forcément un peu
trompé moi sur mes vidéos en format 16/9
donc ça fait beaucoup kron p mais c'est
vrai comme ça c'est quand même hyper
agréable hyper immersif est vraiment
vraiment vraiment jolie puisque je vous
parle d'expérience de cinéma vous avez
en termes d'audio je vous de ma faim ici
un haut parleur sur le côté et un
deuxième haut parleurs en face à des
suisses qui sait que vous avez du son
stéréo et en plus de ça il ya un truc
qui est vachement cool si vous avez de
la vibration du monde que pouvait lui
renvoyer la faute à france est quand
même relativement fort vous avez de la
libration dynamique ce qui fait que sur
des moments un peu intense au niveau du
son et des masses et bien ça veut dire
faire vibrer le smartphone à prévenir
faire régler soit m soit l'enlever vous
le régler comme vous voulez c'est pas
bien grave mais c'est vrai que c'est
quand même vachement agréable
au début je n'ai pas trop mais c'est
vrai que je trouve que au final c'est
quand même assez sympa et vous le voyez
malgré tout on a quand même vachement
faux le son est assez qu'allié alors on
n'a pas la même direction du fond du
coeur j'ai vraiment directes face à caen
et plus en extérieur mais c'est vrai que
c'est quand même hyper appréciable
l'expérience si vous l'écoutez comme ça
directement en façade ça marche bien
mais la meilleure expérience vous l'avez
quand même avec le casque et notamment
avec le casque de sony le haut de gamme
le wh1 ericsson 3 j'ai déjà testé qui
vraiment un excellent casque et si vous
voulez profiter d'une superbe expérience
je ne peux que vous conseiller
il est compatible ld acea ptx
hd high résolution est aussi hybrid
engine wireless vous et profitez d'une
très haute résolution directement de
votre casque bluetooth en bluetooth 5.0
ça c'est vachement bien alors bien
évidemment il y aussi du dolby et moss
et en termes de performance et pas du
tout un smartphone qui dépérit parce que
vous avez ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui
vous avez le qualcomm snapdragon 855 si
giga de ram 128 go de stockage
extensible jusqu'à 512 giga ce
smartphone qui est cool et vous avez un
petit mode je vous retrouver partout en
surimpression que la petite télécommande
folle côté la spa s'il voyait que petit
contrôleur vous appuyez dessus votre
donc un mode je vous ai pouvoir régler
vos performances réglage des priorités
la recherche des captures d'écran impôts
même venir enregistrer directement vos
parties votre gameplay pour l'expérience
de gaming
cet écran avec ce format patin de vienne
est tout simplement génial lol l'amour
de ce carton pour moi c'est un des gros
points forts de ce smartphone c'est le
côté multimédia il a un écran 4 k qui
est tout simplement incroyable qualité
est vraiment top
hyper bien calibré lo'jo et bien vous
avez de super qualité audio vous
l'écoutez comme ça ou directement
castres il ya beaucoup de performances
on est donc sur une vraie machine de
guerre est un smartphone tu vraiment
très très très très impressionnant ce
côté là le point qui revient un peu en
dessous c'est l'autonomie avec une
batterie de 3330 milliampères heures
même si vous avez de la recharge rapide
un champ avec un chargeur 18 watts
l'autonomie n'est pas complètement
dingue en fonction de ce que vous allez
faire bien évidemment vous allez pouvoir
garder une journée et lire plus et c'est
aujourd'hui ce qui est dommage avec une
proposition comme celle là on laissera
aux smartphones et coûte quand même 999
euros quasiment mis le holà sur un
smartphone très haut gamme avec un écran
d'un 'gap' des très belles finitions
avec une dalle quatre cas qui a consommé
et derrière il y manque un petit peu de
jus ça c'est quand même un peu dommage
alors après point positif en peu près
une demi heure de charge de lui mettre
un peu plus de 50 % d'autonomie donc ça
c'est bien vous allez être obligé de
recharger tous les jours et peut-être
des fois faire un petit renfort dans la
journée si vous avez un peu gourmand
derrière ça c'est un peu le le point en
demi teinte du point de vue lui est
tombé sur un android 9 bail avec la
surcouche experia du wild qui marche
bien qui est très proche en fait de ce
qu'on peut retrouver sur un android pure
est un des points car vraiment été mis
en avant sur son smartphone
c'est son triple module photo vous avez
donc trois caméras trois caméras de 12
mégapixels le premier objectif ça va
être un 26 mm ce que vous retrouvez en
gros un objectif un peu classique un peu
standard qui ouvre à f 1.6 qui a un
homme de 70
stabilisation optique pour la photo
stabilisation hybride pour la vidéo
enfin standard plutôt bien un deuxième
optique de 16 mm 16 mm et un grand-angle
un gros temps qui a cédé formant quand
même qu'il y ait un grand-angle de 130
degrés est qui ouvre à f 2.4 et vous
avez le troisième 152 mm 52 mm c'est un
tel objectif qui est en train d'avoir un
zoom x 2 qui ouvre à f 2.4 avec un angle
de 45 degrés et à l'avant vous avez une
jolie petite caméra de 8 mégapixels qui
ouvre à f 2.0
avant de le nôtre à peu le résultat ces
trucs faut vraiment intéressante cette
proposition de sony sony se dit allez on
est excellent au niveau de deux écrans
on est excellent aussi au niveau de
l'audio au niveau des consoles on sait
faire des superbes télé et on sait faire
des très beaux appareils photos on va
prendre tout ça et on va tout mettre
dans un smartphone qui est l'objet
technologie que tout le monde avec soin
et c'est la proposition de valeur qui
est vraiment intéressant sur ce
smartphone sais pas si vous vous êtes
vidéaste si vous intéressez à la photo
il ya un très gros point fort de clips
vachement bien chez sony o'neal a du
traitement de l'image et compagnie c'est
vraiment l'eye tracking il va réussir à
reconnaître en eux et faire un suivi qui
car pertinents ça quelle que soit la
distance entre à quelque chose près et
ça c'est vachement bien et ça marche
parfaitement bien le fait d'avoir le
choix aussi tout en 12 mégapixels avec
ce choix là c'est vachement bien c'est
très astucieux c'est très bien et
derrière en plus de vingt logiciel si
les halles tas d'expériences
professionnelles qui permettra vraiment
d'aller faire des belles vidéos au
format 21 9ème de logiciels est juste là
c'est cinéma pro et moi j'aime beaucoup
alors peut-être parce que je fais de la
vidéo mais c'est vraiment un truc qui me
parlent sosa vraiment vraiment fait
alors je vous montre un peu l'idée vous
créez un projet vous choisissez votre
résolution 4k
ou alors vous passez en deux cas c'est
ce que voulait bon nous on va se mettre
en quête cas vous choisissez ensuite
votre nombre d'image par seconde
30 images par seconde 24 images par
seconde cinéma c'est peut-être dû 24
images par seconde nous on va se mettre
en 30 images par seconde
et vous savez si on suit votre look
c'est à dire un peu là la colorimétrie
de votre image par défaut vous avez
différentes colorimétrie et ça c'est
vrai que c'est quand même vachement
gallard en fonction de là vous allez y
de ce que vous voulez savoir comment du
vous avez ça et je trouve que c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment très sympa
fait vraiment quasiment tout ce que vous
voulez on va se mettre en doute moi
personnellement j'aime beaucoup
ensuite vous cherchez votre objectif
soit le 26 mm qui est un petit peu
standard qui ouvre à f 1.6 soit 16 mm
quel grand temps vous à dire tout de
suite ça vous fait un très grand angle
ou alors carrément fois ci sur le 52 mm
ouvre à f 2.4 qu'ils aiment ou faire un
tel objectif à zoom x 2 et voyez c'est
assez bluffant
j'aime beaucoup alors on va se mettre
sur le 26 mm qui dirait que vous allez
pouvoir retrouver usuellement sûr
beaucoup beaucoup de smartphones vous
réglez vos iso à vous monter jusqu'à 800
iso et vous aller sinon jusqu'à tout en
bas en 64 iso votre luminosité moi j'ai
rien d'automatique ça va très bien
l'obturateur et ensuite vous avez votre
mise au point automatique pas au point
comme vous voulez donc ça c'est cool et
vous avez un petit résumé siècle usb
avec le codec le niveau de batterie
restant la mémoire prises les lignes de
cadrage vous appuyer là ça file vous
appuyer là où ça fait une photo et après
vous avez accès aux fichiers donc si
vous voulez tourner des vidéos qualité
cinéma vous avez pas avoir à la réelle
qualité cinéma ne vous trouvez un petit
outil qui vient peut pas ému les sam et
travaille en tout cas dans ce sens on
sent vraiment très très intéressant et
même le rendu au niveau des photos
photos un petit peu standard est
vraiment bien là vous avez le
grand-angle alors il ya un côté kamel
qui est des formes ans vous en rendrez
compte sur une photo un peu plus loin
là vous êtes sur l'objectif standard de
26 mm et là vous êtes sur le zoom x 2 là
c'est pareil vous être sur le l'ultra
grand-angle je vais arriver ensuite sur
l'appareil 26 mm standard et ensuite le
téléobjectif zoom x de pareilles très
grand-angle appareils normal le zoom x 2
et à chaque fois briller on a une
colorimétrie et très vite on a un souci
du détail ça marche parfaitement bien
alors des fois je trouve qu'il a un
petit peu de mal certains endroits à
venir ici voyez il a coûté un peu sur
exposé mais c'est très léger s'annonce
plutôt bien et là vous arrivez sur les
caméras trafic je trouve en plus marche
vachement bien il ya pareil c'est la
caméra principale une fois 2 et la lutte
sera jean d'angle et là vous le voyez
vraiment le côté déformant de l' ultra
grand-angle dans le miroir ça fait le
taf mais c'est vrai que là ils ont
vraiment mis en avant le côté fisheye
déformant l'armée sur la caméra standard
ça marche il ya le coup à fond très
juste c'est ce vraiment ce que j'aime
c'est qu'ils vont pas chercher à avoir
un rendu sursaturé c'est très naturel
c'est très neutre l' appareil photo
standard la joue seul grand temps une
voix tout de suite comme ces déformant
et là le téléobjectif avec le zoom x 2
ils en arrivent en photo une nuit alors
en photo nue c'est tout de suite un peu
moins bon alors je me photos nues voir
dépendantes avait pas beaucoup de
lumière moment où j'ai pris cette photo
il a un petit peu de mal à faire le
point qui a assez de bruit le la qualité
là dessus pas extraordinaire j'en ai
fait 12e avec le zoom x 2 bon c'est pas
génial
par contre un truc qui est assez
impressionnant c'est la façon dont il va
pouvoir reconnaître effectivement les
yeux regardez la commune reconnaît
l'oeil du perso et comme il ya faire le
point en fonction de ça ça pour moi
c'est tout simplement vraiment très
impressionnant et c'est là où on va en
tout cas le boulot
le beau boulot l'adaptation qui est
faite par sony de cette technologie qui
est intégré dans son smartphone et sa
voyez je peu décalés je peux bouger
il ya un vrai bon track il assure pas
aussi bon que ce que vous allez voir sur
des boîtiers qui coûte tout de suite
beaucoup plus cher mais en attendant
cette techno est là elle est intégrée et
ça c'est vachement bien et du coup
laurent duc ça vous donne en vidéo est
tout simplement il perd qualitatif je
vous conseille vraiment d'utiliser
l'application cinéma pro qui marche
parfaitement alors c'est pas une
application qui va être utilisé par
monsieur madame tout le monde ça peut
l'être la limite il est de ce smartphone
nous intègrent toutes ces belles
technologie mais là avec ce statut lui
on va plus se destiner à des vidéastes
pas monsieur madame tout le monde
quelques matchs aujourd'hui j'ai filmé
avec celui celui là je suis pas persuadé
c'était un peu la limite de ce
smartphone qui s'adresse plus un public
donc cette partie là que pour autre
chose en tout cas c'est un vrai parti
pris c'est une bonne intégration de
tecno c'est complètement maîtrisé de la
part de sony se trouve ça vraiment bien
fait même filmé en 960 images par
seconde en full hd si tu peux mettre à
faire du super slow motion
ça c'est cool et le rendu le résultat de
ce que vous allez pouvoir filmer avec
l'application est pour moi tout
simplement hyper impressionnant c'est
bien sympa c'est pas pour me sied bien à
tout le monde une fois de plus mais en
tout cas le rendu est vraiment calme ce
smartphone qui est certifié ip 68 ip65
et du nfc pour le témoin dématérialisée
et que je trouve moi personnellement
très complet très bien très beau j'adore
j'aime beaucoup cette proposition faite
par sony sony c'est une marque que
j'aime bien je vais déjà dit plusieurs
fois ci aussi mes vidéos jeunes certains
feignent ne parle pas assez de poids
tous les produits sony que j'ai pu avoir
et en plus jeune et je continue à
apprécier cette marque elle est un peu
plus en retrait au niveau des
smartphones mais elle continue d'innover
à faire des propositions intéressantes
là dessus il ya une vraie belle
proposition c'est vraiment très
intéressant si vous cherchez un
smartphone à exigeant au niveau de la
qualité de votre écran si vous avez lu
audio de qualité si vous voulez un très
bon appareil photo pouvait y aller alors
il sera pas aussi bon que pour avoir
avec un pixel croît pas aussi bon que
pour avoir avec un point de plus cette
promesse la qualité l'écran est dingue
c'est dommage c'est vraiment dommage que
la batterie soit un peu en fout j'espère
que sony nous proposera un produit il
perd évolué avec des photos au top et
bien au dessus de ce qui se fait à la
concurrence avec une énorme batterie et
là par contre ils feraient qui perd mal
avec une très très belle proposition
d'accord il ya quelques petits points
encore à c'est un peu dommage qu'ils le
font un peu buté et qui font que c'est
pas le smartphone qui est pas ce
smartphone en tout cas si on y va dans
le bon sens une super proposition mais
moi je trouve hyper cool et d'ailleurs
si vous intéresse il ya un pack en ce
moment à la fnac
vous pouvez acheter le sony xperia one
et le casque w/h melix m3 au tarif
du smartphone seuls 5 août 1304 tarif
normal et vous trouve à 999 euros
ce smartphone nous intéresse si vous
n'avez pas encore le casque à réduction
de bruit sony pour y aller parce que
vous aurez un super pac et j'ai mis un
lien en bas dans la description ce
smartphone je trouve bien si vous aimez
sony si vous recherchez un bel écran
vous l'un produits qualité il est cool
c'est un peu dommage pour la batterie
pour l'autonomie mais si vous avez la
p6t de leurs charges et toujours avoir
le chargeur avec vous ça vous le
regretterez pas à vous de nous dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
quant à moi vous êtes des gros becs
bisou à plus tard